Aww yeah! What's up guys? Today we are learning
English with a beautiful Disney Pixar film, Coco.
So this film shows a very interesting Mexican
tradition called the Day of The Dead. Now,
Mexican culture is very present in the United
States because they're our neighbor to the south
and also because there has been a lot of
immigration from Mexico. Now we first will
look at a funny clip from the movie which is full
of fantastic vocabulary and phrasal verbs and then
we'll also take a look at one of the songs.
So finally this film also includes a lot of
Spanish words which we'll show the English
translation for in green. Let's jump in.
Alright, so, in just a moment we are going
to learn all the most important vocabulary,
phrasal verbs, and even pronunciation from that
clip, but first I wanted to quickly let you know
that if you are new here every single week we
make fun lessons just like this one so that
you can learn to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles. Just like our fan
Nikki who says that she was bored all of
her life learning with traditional methods and
now it's fun for her learning with our channel.
And if you want to have a ton of fun
and learn lots too it's really simple
you can join over 3 million learners
from around the world by hitting that
subscribe button and the bell down below and
you won't miss a single one of our new lesson.
Now a lot of learners tell me that they
can't understand natives because we
speak too fast but did you know this
isn't actually the real problem?
The real issue is that we cut and connect
our words together like you've just seen
here but you can learn this and be able to
understand natives at any speed. And we have
a free three-part masterclass that will help
you a lot in being able to do it so if you
want to try that absolutely free you can click
up here or down description below to learn more.
Hey if you're enjoying this lesson
then I bet you will absolutely
adore this other lesson we
made with the Pixar classic
UP you can find that clicking up here or down
description below after you finish this lesson.